coupled reactions use a
thermodynamically favorable reaction to
drive a thermodynamically unfavorable
reaction for example let's look at a
hypothetical reaction where reactants a
and b combine to form products c and i
the standard change in free energy for
this reaction delta g naught let's say
is greater than zero and when delta g
naught is greater than zero that's a
thermodynamically unfavorable reaction
and at equilibrium the equilibrium
constant k is less than one when k is
less than one that means there are more
reactants than products at equilibrium
and if our goal is to make a lot of the
product c
that won't happen as long as this
reaction is thermodynamically
unfavorable
next let's look at another hypothetical
reaction where i reacts with d to form e
and f as the products for this
hypothetical reaction the standard
change in free energy delta g naught is
much less than zero
since delta g naught for this second
hypothetical reaction is less than zero
reaction two is thermodynamically
favorable and at equilibrium the
equilibrium constant k is much greater
than 1. if k is much greater than 1 then
we can assume that the second reaction
essentially goes to completion so all
the i and the d will react together to
form e and f and at equilibrium there
are way more products than there are
reactants
remember that our goal was to make a lot
of the product c but we can't get that
by just running the first reaction by
itself
however by coupling the first reaction
which is thermodynamically unfavorable
to the second reaction which is
thermodynamically favorable we can make
a significant amount of product c these
two hypothetical reactions can be
coupled together because they share a
common intermediate eye even though
reaction one is thermodynamically
unfavorable even if it forms only a
small amount of eye since reaction two
is thermodynamically favorable the i
from reaction 1 will be used up in
reaction 2 to form the products for
reaction 2.
removing the product i causes the
equilibrium to shift to the right in the
first reaction therefore producing more
of our desired product c
so the thermodynamically favorable
reaction is driving the
thermodynamically unfavorable reaction
to the right since we are coupling these
two reactions together if we add
reaction 1 to reaction 2 the
intermediate would cancel out and for
the reactants we would get a plus b plus
d and for the products we would get c
plus e plus f
to find delta g naught for this overall
equation we would need to add together
delta g naught for reaction one and
delta g naught for reaction two
so delta g naught for this overall
equation would be less than zero which
tells us this overall equation is
thermodynamically favorable and the
equilibrium constant is greater than 1
which means at equilibrium we'll have a
decent amount of our desired product c
next let's look at a practical example
of coupled reactions let's say that our
goal is to extract solid copper from
copper one sulfide the other product of
this reaction is sulfur however delta g
naught for this reaction is equal to
positive 86.1 kilojoules per mole of
reaction since delta g naught is
positive this reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable and at
equilibrium there'd be very little of
our product so we wouldn't get very much
copper
the solution is to couple this first
reaction to a thermodynamically
favorable reaction and that's the
conversion of sulfur into sulfur dioxide
so solid sulfur plus oxygen gas gives
sulfur dioxide and delta g naught for
this reaction is equal to negative 300.4
kilojoules per mole of reaction
so adding our two reactions together the
common intermediate sulfur cancels out
and that gives us copper one sulfide
plus oxygen for the reactants
goes to copper solid copper and sulfur
dioxide for the products
and if we add the two delta g naught
values together positive 86.1 plus
negative 300.4
gives a delta g naught for this overall
equation equal to negative
214.3 kilojoules per mole of reaction
since delta g naught is negative now
this overall reaction is
thermodynamically favorable with an
equilibrium constant greater than one
therefore we will now produce a lot of
copper so burning copper one sulfide in
air gives us a feasible way of
extracting copper from copper one
sulfide
coupled reactions are also very
important in biochemistry for example
two amino acids are alanine and glycine
and if these two amino acids come
together they form what's called a
dipeptide it's very important for the
body to be able to make dipeptides
because if we were to add on some more
amino acids we would form what's called
a polypeptide which eventually leads to
the formation of a protein however the
formation of dipeptides is
thermodynamically unfavorable therefore
the body needs a way of making this
reaction thermodynamically favorable so
the body can make proteins to do this
the body uses atp which stands for
adenosine
triphosphate and here is the dot
structure for atp in the ionized form
atp is often called a high energy
compound and the hydrolysis of atp is
used to drive protein synthesis
next let's look at the equation showing
the hydrolysis of atp to adp which is
adenosine diphosphate and inorganic
phosphate the standard change in free
energy for the hydrolysis of atp is
equal to negative 31 kilojoules per mole
of reaction since delta g naught is
negative the hydrolysis of atp is
thermodynamically favorable
alanine and glycine combine to form the
dipeptide alone glycine and water delta
g naught for the formation of this
dipeptide is equal to positive 29
kilojoules per mole of reaction
since delta g naught is positive this
reaction is thermodynamically
unfavorable with the help of an enzyme
the unfavorable reaction is coupled to
the favorable reaction and if we add the
two reactions together water would
cancel out and give us alanine plus
glycine plus atp for the reactants
and alkanyl glycine and adp and
inorganic phosphate for the products
adding the two values of delta g naught
together we get delta g naught is equal
to negative two kilojoules per mole of
reaction
and since delta g naught is negative
it's now favorable for the body to
synthesize this dipeptide